could Red Hulk finally be making his way
to the MCU there was a little bit of
evidence for this and Avengers in game
and now it appears that we have more
evidence that he's going to be coming to
the MCU sooner than later how's it going
everybody it's Warren and yesterday we
got some pretty big news on the set of
Black Widow William Hurt was spotted on
the set of Black Widow and of course
William Hurt plays Thunderbolt Ross in
the MCU and if you're not aware of who
Thunderbolt Ross is in the comics he is
Red Hulk and these photos that Red Hulk
has been spotted in make us believe that
Red Hulk is about to make an appearance
in the MCU sooner than later I'll break
down what Thunderbolt Ross showing up on
the set of Black Widow means and why
it's evidence that Red Hulk has come
into the MCU in this video but first be
sure to subscribe to my channel and
leave a like and a comment on it so you
can enter my giveaway for a chance to
win an Xbox one or a ps4 now I can't
show these photos in the video because
they are owned by just Jarrod calm but
I'll link them in the description down
below and they really do have a pretty
significant meaning now for starters
these were released yesterday and the
Black Widow filming has already wrapped
this leads many of us to believe that
William Hurt was there to film the
post-credits scene for Black Widow and
what is really interesting about William
Hertz in these photos is that he doesn't
really look like Thunderbolt Ross yes it
is Thunderbolt Ross you can clearly tell
it's him but he does look a little bit
different he looks older weaker sicker
and his clothes are a little bit baggy
could this be the result of him
experimenting on himself to try and
become Red Hulk now for a really quick
backstory about Red Hulk for those of
you who do not know Red Hulk is the
result of Ross experimenting on himself
to try and give himself powers to combat
their original Green Hulk it ultimately
ends up working but Ross manages to keep
his intelligence so it's essentially
like a smart Hulk from avengers endgame
the Hulk's body but Bruce banners mind
or in this case the red Hulk's body and
Ross's mind now you may not think that
the fact that he looks weak and feeble
and he's leaning on a cane really means
anything but let's take a look at
Avengers infinity war and Avengers end
game remember Black Widow is going to
take place between the events of Civil
War and Avengers infinity war
in Avengers infinity war even though he
was a hologram you could tell that he
was in really good shape he looks very
healthy and he sounds healthy as well
and he clearly seems to be in good
enough shape to walk without a cane and
he's wearing a suit that fits really
well so he goes from right after the
events of Civil War looking very very
sick and weak to being perfectly fine
and healthy in Avengers infinity war now
of course we know that Marvel does not
follow the comics to the tee they draw
inspiration from the comics so general
Ross becoming Red Hulk to better combat
the original Green Hulk doesn't really
make much sense but perhaps he could be
experimenting on a way to make him
better from whatever sickness that he
has and the result could be him turning
into the Red Hulk because how exactly
could he go from looking very sick and
very weak right after the events of
Civil War right before the events of
Avengers infinity war and right before
the events of Avengers in game where he
is also seen at the end of the movie
looking very normal and very healthy it
doesn't really make much sense but
perhaps he somehow found a cure to it
that also happened to make him become
the Red Hulk and perhaps he could
somehow find a way to control turning
into the Red Hulk much like Bruce Banner
in the first Avengers film and there's
also the chance that him being this sick
and weak could be the result of him
experimenting on himself because in
civil war he was also normal-looking as
well he looked perfectly healthy and
Black Widow takes place right after
Civil War so how could he go from being
perfectly healthy to looking very sick
well perhaps it's the result of him
experimenting on himself to try and give
himself powers because the sokovia
accords didn't exactly go the way he
planned and he pretty much learned that
he can't control the Avengers he can't
control people with powers they're just
too strong so how do you combat that how
do you fight against them well you give
yourself powers and you're probably not
going to get it right right away so this
sick and weak state that we see him in
could be the result of him experimenting
and then when we see him looking healthy
again in Avengers infinity war and
Avengers and game he could have figured
it out so could this be a setup for the
Red Hulk there is evidence to support
the fact that it could be happening
after all we are getting a she-hulk
coming to Disney Plus perhaps the Red
Hulk is going to make an appearance in
the MCU as well because after all
Thunderbolt Ross's first appearance was
in the Incredible Hulk movie he has been
in the MCU for an incredibly long time
one of the oldest characters in the MCU
and since Marvel cannot do a solo Hulk
film perhaps they are going to introduce
Red Hulk as a way to compensate for that
as well but be sure to let me know your
thoughts on this what do you think about
these pictures why do you think he looks
so sick and weak do you think it's a
result of him experimenting on himself
trying to give himself powers and do you
think he looks better in infinity war
because he finally figures it out be
sure to let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below and again don't
forget to subscribe like the video and
leave a comment so you can enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or a ps4 you can also click the link in
the description down below for your
chance to win a Nintendo switch and if
you want to follow me on instagram and
twitter i do random giveaways on there
as well as always this is Warren and
thank you all so much for watching Wolf
Wolf